so wait you're about to be this is
literally my my kids like one of their
favorite characters all the time is
Ursula and you're about to do this in
the live action like Little Mermaid yes
are you so stoked I mean you have the
best song her unfortunate soul yeah it's
so weird because when I was a nanny
um I I worked for this lovely the Ross
family hi Rosses and we watched Little
Mermaid almost every night so I truly
was like for three years I watched it
almost every night yeah and to get to
play it and to work with like Rob
Marshall and just the whole because I
don't get to be in your world of like
singing and sliding down a clamshell and
then truly the clam show was like you
know it was the best song did you feel
so powerful singing that song I was
scared to death
and then I worked with somebody and then
I was like okay it's just a character I
don't have to be I don't have to be a
singer I can just be this character but
I love that song and when it's when we
finally recorded it and they're like
that's it you've got your song I
literally burst out crying because I was
like oh I don't get to go to singing
class anymore like that's
it'd be weird if you've kept if you kept
going it would be awesome that would be
weird not your Friday night dress up in
a box of chocolates like that's your
that's your line we found it okay how
many of y'all are Gilmore Girl fans
y'all fans okay
can't talk can't talk me too and so now
Sookie St James and I are about to go
head to head in a trivia battle we're
calling who's more
me that's how it's gonna I'm talking a
lot of smack I haven't seen an episode
in a while so it's gonna be good I've
never seen it since I did it
here's how it's gonna work I'll ask you
10 questions relating to Gilmore Girls
wait Alex this doesn't work we need a
host we need I can't host and play so
who's asking the questions I am Kelly
using my powerful and very sexy voice
for little
I'm not
however I am the greatest Gilmore fan in
the universe so it's only fitting that I
asked the questions and be the judge all
right will you also re-record my
outgoing message
[Laughter]
all right you got it girl I'm going to
leave I will read a series of questions
about Gilmore now the first one to buzz
in has five seconds to answer now if
you're correct you'll get one point but
if you're incorrect or don't answer in
time the other person can steal okay
okay
you really that might get close yeah God
got a little sexy all right all right
most points wins and the winner will
receive the most cherished thing on this
Earth
no an Amazon gift card
I Wanna Live Forever
that's good I am a Prime member so I'm
ready you ready you ready to play yes
here's your first question
dinner with the grandparents happened on
which day we kind of did the same time
I'm gonna say Friday night that is
correct
thank you okay okay I gotta be quicker
yeah Melissa one Kelly zero oh thank you
for the reminder guys thank you here's
your next question when Jackson met
Sookie what was his occupation oh
he was a he
CK your balls he's got to throw the
vegetables here's the gardener will we
expect vegetables
so close
he was my produce delivery guy oh God
that was okay that is correct
Frozen
with produce
the vegetables I know that's not a right
answer I know God I got it wrong she's
got two are you going to question me
let's move on question number three
Diner used to be a what
hardware stores
now that you say it it's all coming back
to me once again to Kelly one oh thank
you he is beating your butt right now
oh my God all right here's the next
question
how did Rory break her arm
uh car accident Jesse oh yes yes it is
correct I said yes
because Laura and I was like he's about
influence and she was like he's so cool
I love the intensity in which you scream
that day into my face I know Jane Lynch
doesn't like playing games with me I
love it I love an aggressive gameplay I
have a tie game and I'm gonna need a
drink myself after this
here's the next question originally how
many children did Jackson want with
Sookie
six
I'm sorry that's way wrong
I was gonna say four
[Music]
[Applause]
it's very rock and roll we now have
ourselves a game as Kelly the host of
the show now has three points to
Melissa's just to remind you okay three
and you've got not as much now at the
moment which just means boy that Victory
is going to be sweet
question number seven Lorelei named her
dog after who
known a singer it's the artist it's a
it's a um oh no no it's a it's the
artist the singer it's the old dude I
can't remember well the answer you were
looking for was of course Paul Anka
oh my God it's even yes we are dumb okay
you said it I didn't say it you did
and now our next question oh my God
that's right
there's so much Spirit where did Jackson
propose to Sookie
uh in uh next to Mr
grass
[Music]
[Applause]
That was supposed to be at noon and we
shot it at like one o'clock in the
morning so we were just under like
crazy Kling lights trying to make it
look like daylight so we couldn't really
look at each other because it was so
bright I was like I do I
it was so bright we couldn't see each
other we're like oh
no see acting sounds hard okay all right
now we have a tie game here okay and
this is the final question for the game
I feel great about it and here it is
okay okay how did Jackson ask Suki out
on their first date
congratulations
[Applause]
oh my God
Melissa on a new season of Little Big
Shots on NBC thanks guys
[Applause]
you did a happy birthday post for your
husband which is sweet but I thought
this was cooler because I actually just
saw isn't he cute yeah but look at to
the right that's Barbara yeah yeah she's
just commenting on your feed just like
it's a day that ends and why so like
it's just like it's when I see that I'm
normally like well when I wake him up in
the hospital from my fever dream and
it's like I know Barbra Streisand
they're like you don't I'll be like okay
it was a great dream but yeah I see that
and at first I thought does she think
that at first I wanted does Barbara
think I've had a child
and then I was like that's really so
flattering because I'm 100.
[Laughter]
see until recently I'm gonna mess up the
title but it's something like the magic
the memories the music she did this
whole thing this whole show that I
literally watched the other night um on
Netflix I believe it was
um but it was on something and I had no
idea about that whole Duets album she
did the show was a tremendous but I then
you did a song with her on it as well oh
so crazy
yes but also when they called I
literally was like no first of all I
don't know who this is I like my manager
called and he's like Barbra Streisand
wants to do duet with you I'm like well
I think that's rude I don't know who's
punking me
because I don't do that and then he was
like I know I was English to mean
spirited I'd do anything to meet her and
then they're like no she really you know
she thinks she can do it will you go
meet her and what are you gonna say now
I was like yeah yes and she's great and
I think the magic I think meeting her
was already kind of surreal yeah but
then what I didn't I there's certain
people that I expect to be like I'm
Barbra Streisand yeah I thought she
would like float in on like a cashmere
cloud and again it'd just be like caviar
and diamonds and she was so kind of like
let's talk about like how to make it
better how can we work on that she was
all processed like in a fun way yeah but
she still has the love of what she's
doing and it's still like how do we do a
little better like what do you think and
I was like I'm not telling you anything
I'm certainly not going to give you a
note a note she's like do you like this
or this I'm like I like what you like
and she's like that doesn't help me
she's like what which way is better and
then I was like
for the first way Barbra Streisand and
then once we got into it I realized she
wants the note she wants to work
collaboratively yeah and I was like the
fact that even at that level she's still
like let's work it out let's and to me
that just that was the coolest part and
she's really funny oh my gosh no that's
what I thought was amazing um she did
this whole show yeah that I saw and I
thought what a what a talented person to
give to person what an exciting thing to
be still inspired like you know what I'm
saying like still this many years later
you see that whole career that you're a
part of you're a part of that career
it's insane anyway I just happened to
see it and then I was like she's all in
your feed and I'm like okay I want your
life
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Applause]
is